se acuerdan que hablábamos de una dieta
baja en sodio este vídeo lo que logrará
es ver con los productos diarios que
vemos en la calle que tanto estamos
cubriendo este tipo de dieta o no
hablemos que esta dieta baja en sodio
está alrededor de 1000
500 miligramos de sodio diario
pongamos aquí que es diario
pensando que voy en la calle y me orilló
compro uno de estos paquetes grandes de
papas fritas
obviamente me gusta comer menos con cats
así es que dibujaré cinco sobrecitos de
cats up
pongámosle el nombre papas fritas eso es
lo que me comí y llegando a la oficina
tampoco puedo salir a comer por lo que
pido uno de estos vasos de sopa
instantánea estos que tienen fideos aquí
en medio y hasta trocitos de res o
camarón y esa es mi comida pongamos vaso
de sopa instantánea ya sé que no estoy
comiendo adecuadamente sin embargo
estamos tomando estos ejemplos de la
vida diaria
sigue transcurriendo el día y me voy a
casa y al revisar la alacena me doy
cuenta que solo tengo uno de estos
bloques que también son de sopa
instantánea solo que son más grandes así
es que lo colocaré en una cacerola llena
con agua coloco mi bloque
y a esta escena lo llamaremos como tal
bloque de sopa instantánea ok
estos son mis alimentos del día de hoy
que tanto estoy cubriendo o no mi dieta
de 1.500 miligramos de sodio vamos a
analizar cada uno de los productos que
hemos consumido el día de hoy y veremos
que las papas fritas tienen 900
miligramos de sodio
el vaso de sopa instantánea tiene 1200
miligramos mientras que el bloque de
sopa instantánea tiene 1.600 miligramos
con este simple bloque de sopa ya
hubiese cubierto mi dieta baja en sodio
investigando en internet encontré una
página de una clínica que se llama mayo
clinic está en inglés así es que se
escribe en mayo clinic y aquí me
permiten hacer un plato donde puedo
colocar diferentes productos en este
caso encontré el salmón el cual solo
tiene 60 miligramos de sodio lo cual me
puso muy feliz para no extrañar las
papas que comí hace un momento coloque
papas rostizada de éstas que tienen
especias y sales y así son muy ricas y
solo tienen 7 miligramos de sodio
mamá siempre me decía que colocara algo
verde en cada comida
así es que colocar en un poco de
espárragos con champiñones
y vamos a colocar que los champiñones y
estos espárragos tendrán solo 11
miligramos de sodio creo que voy
bastante bien así es que me permitiré un
postre se me antoja una rebanada de que
será de pay de manzana
se me hace agua la boca este pay de
manzana únicamente tiene 16 miligramos
de sodio si hacemos la sumatoria de
todos estos ingredientes tenemos que 60
miligramos del salmón más 7 miligramos
de las papas rostizada se acuerdan los
espárragos tenían 11 miligramos y el pay
de manzana únicamente 16 miligramos
sumamos todo esto y nos da un total de
94 miligramos se dan cuenta 94
miligramos en toda una comida incluso
con postre de esta manera tengo más
chance de alcanzar mi dieta baja en
sodio nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo